(bruits de l'outil)
- Râper les dents d'un cheval
pour éviter qu'elles ne blessent
sa bouche; l'intervention,
inusitée, fait pourtant partie
du quotidien de Julia
Chamberlin.
♪ ♪ ♪
Spécialisée dans les soins aux
grands animaux, elle nous avait
donné rendez-vous dans ce centre
équestre de Montérégie, où sont
gardés une trentaine de chevaux.
JULIA CHAMBERLIN,
vétérinaire équine
- Le mot se passe dans
l'écurie : "Ah, la vétérinaire,
elle s'en vient vendredi!"
Fait que là, bien, les gens
retontissent. Finalement,
on a fini avec deux râpages de
dents, puis une dizaine de
vaccins, deux hernies
ombilicales à évaluer.
- Cette demie journée est à
l'image de toute son année.
Julia Chinininin est aussi
appréciée que débordée.
DENIS LONGPRÉ,
éleveur de chevaux
- stststst exceptionnelle,
attentionnée, professionnelle,
énormément. C'est
incontournable, on en a besoin.
C'est ça, c'est une nécessité.
-  Elle s'occupe d'environ
un millier de chevaux et
travaille souvent 80 heures
semaine; en plus d'être sur
appel en cas d'urgen
La Montérégie, où elle pratique,
est malgré tout la région la
mieux desservie de la province.
- En haut de Québec, vers
Tadoussac, touririririve-nord
là, ils n'ont plus personne du
tout pour faire les chevaux
dans ce coin-là.L'L'L'L'Outaoual
desservie et cet été,
un drame a empiré la situation.
Le 31 juillet, la vétérinaire
équine Andrea Kelly s'est
enlevée la vie. Elle avait
36 ans et étaiécécécéciée par
600 clients de l'Ontario et
du Québec.
- Et elle, elle aimait s
les chevaux et les chats.
(rires)
- Marce e e e était son financé.
Il avait beaucoup parlé avec
elle de la lourdeur de sa charge
de travail. Il est persuadé que
c'est la raison principale qui
l'a poussée au suicide.
MARC ALARIE
- Une fois qu'elle a acheté
la clinique, j'ai vu un peu
le stress, le fardeau qui a
commencé à tomber sur elle.
J'ai vu qu'elle n'était plus
la mêmennnnnnnne.
Elle m'en avait parlé un peu,
qu'elle avait des pensées.
Je lui ai sugg c c c consulter.
Mais elle ne voulait pas parce
qu'elle avait un peu peur de
perdre sa licence.
- Depuis sa mort, la clinique
d'Andrea, au sud d'Ottawa, a
fermé définitivement faute de
personnel. Elle avait cherché
pendant des mois desvévévévétérr
avec elle, sans jamais les
trouver.
- Je vais faire en sorte que
sa mémoire, elle reste en vie,
que les gens connaissent qui
c'était, ma copine. Je veux
aussi aider les prochains parce
qu'il y a vraiment un problè
dans ce secteur-là.
- Selon une nouvelle étude,
38 % des vétérinaires québécois
éprouvent des symptômes
semesemesemesement professionne.
16 % d'entre eux ont même eu
des idées suicidaires dans
la semaine précédasosososondage.
À travers le Canada,
c'est plus dt t t t des
vétérinaires qui auraient
songé au suicide en 2020,
selon une e e e étude. Andrea
Kelly n'est pas un cas isolé.
- Sur le coup, j'étais un petit
peu bouleversée parce que
jeisisisis dit : pas un autre;
tu sais. Puis, c'est pas
la première, ce sera sûrement
pas la dernière.
- Je crois vraiment que c'est
respiratoire comme je te disais.
- Claudia Sauvé, elle, soigne
les petits animaux.
CLAUDIA SAUVÉ, vétérinaire
- On le sait, la pression que
cette fille-là, cette
vétérinaire-là a eu sur
les épaules.
- Sa communauté est épuisée
elle-aussi, surtout depuis
la pandémie; 60 % des ménages
canadiens ont maintenant un chat
ou un chien.
- Et on doit refuser des
patients chaque jour. Ça,
c'est quelque chose que
je connaissais pas avant.
Il y a une demande grandissante
pour des vétérinaires, mais
il y en n'a pas de nouveaux
vétérinaires.
- Pourtant, les jeunes
s'intéressent à la profession,
mais le programme en médecine
vétérinaire de St-Hyacinthe,
le seul au Québe t t t très
contingenté. 96 étudiants y
obtiennent leur diplôme chaque
année. Une nouvelle formation
pour 25 auererererra le jour
dans 2 ans à Rimouski.
MARIE ARCHAMBAULT, vice-doyenne
Faculté méd. vétérinaire, UdeM
- On est limité quant aux
espaces qu'on a à la Faculté de
médecine vétérinaire; c'est
pour ça aussi qu'on a ouvert
un campus à Rimouski, pour
favoriser les régions éloignées
- On fait beaucoup de route,
on se rend sur les fermes.
Écoute, c'est 50 à 55 000 kilos
par année.
- Le défi, rappelle Julia
Chamberlin, est aussi de garder
les nouveaux vétérinaires.
- Quasiment 50 % des
vétérinaires qui commencent
en pratique équine lâchent
la pratique; c'est é
Ils trouvent ça trop dur.
Les gardes, les fins de
semaine, les soirs, le
psychologique qu'il faut gérer
aussi avec la clientèle.
- Difficile parfois quand elle
doit euthanasier un animal.
- Puis la dame qui est
complètement couchée sur son
cheval et qui est en sanglots,
puis moi je suis là avec
ma seringue puis il faut que
je la pousse, l'euthanyl, là.
C'est sûr que les larmes me
coulent, là
- Difficile aussi quand
la facture est élevée.
- Les gens ne sont pas habitués
de payer pour des soins
médicaux; les soins médicaux
sont chers, les équipements sont
chers, les médicaments sont
dispendieux.
- C'est vraiment l'aspect
financier qui est le plus
difficile. Aquququque jour,
constamment, on doit
s'expliquer, on doit dire
pourquoi c'est dispendieux.
Je pense que tout le monde,
on a entendu la phrase :
"Oui, mais on le sait bien, vous
autres les vétérinaires, vous le
faites juste pour le cash!"
- À Ste-Hyacinthe, une révision
du programme est en cours.
- Oui, on peut s'améliorer
pour permettre aux futurs
médecins vétérinaires d'être
encore mieux équipés, pour
augmenter la résilience,
faire face au stress et
apprendre à mettre ses limites.
- Julia Chamberlin continue
d'adorer son métier, mais elle
est parfois à bout de souffle.
- Une chance; mon conjoint est
là pour me supporter et m'aider
parce que sans lui, ça
marcherait pas. J'ai deux grands
garçons : un de 12 a9 9 9 9 ans.
Je pense que je trouve
mon équilibre à faire des
activités avec eux.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Elle nous a salués et est
ieieieie soigner d'autres
chevaux.
♪ ♪